hi guys and you know who I am so I
shouldn't really bother to even tell you
guys I am so hurt in case you didn't
know yet watch my video anyway
yet somehow find out about my channel
but not know what my name is whatever I
am I am going to upload this video again
and I'm recording this right now and
which is a miracle because for the past
three weeks I think I've been pretty
inactive I'm sorry about that I've been
uploading old videos during that time by
the way because first of all I had
vacation then I was ill terrible flu
everything almost dead thankfully I'm
still alive I survived it thanks to
medical wonders of our society and then
school happened and for projects and
boom boom stress and hell and now I am
here and I can play roller coaster
tycoon 3 which is my job my full-time
you know up in my life this is all I'm
looking for it's my goal in my life
basically so what are we going to do
today we are going to make some paths so
that's what we're going to do we are
going to take the path finger bobber and
do something if this game won't allow me
to so I really need to get back into
this I feel like I haven't done this in
years it feels like skiing for the first
time in my life again yeah so this I
think oh whoops I already messed up
wrong collar see this this is what
happens if I don't pay attention to what
I'm doing I'm just going to timely I'm
little over talking is really high today
I'm just going to time-lapse this real
quick and then come back to you
as the Sun steps down landscapes today
who calmly walk away
going from the frame when struck the
truth falls
once again
with collars faith and it turns to gray
who calmly walk away walk away from the
fray when structure falls and all else
fails we will build it once again me for
only could stand by
while it bursts
we cannot fly
as we've
well then the main walk way next to the
lift Hill is pretty much finished I
think I kind of like the way it looks
it's kind of like I had in mind not as
detailed though I mean I'm a man of
details and people always whine and
[ __ ] about that whatever just let me do
what I want to do now I think I can
still do some more things in here it
still looks a bit bare and yes sure I
can add some sidewalks over here but not
what it's it's already a sidewalk fest
in this park I'm not going to place any
more sidewalks like that and camera
stripping but I really like the fact
that you can please behave I really like
the fact that you have the river over
here and a nice little view on the
wooden roller coaster with the walkway
with all the trees and stuff nature also
the contrast between the very classical
and Roman side of the river over here
and the other side which is more German
of course the northern part of the Roman
Empire all that blah blah blah some
Roman influences but mostly German and
yeah that's that's about it for this
episode and although I think that this
flat rot this flat right looks a bit
boring I'm probably going to add some I
don't know things planners and stuff and
trees around this some lights and some
other flat right over here probably a
restaurants in here I want to have some
kind of a somewhat busy area over here
and then just finish it over there maybe
maybe even have a walkway on the other
side of the woody not all the way around
it though because start I don't know it
would kind of suck I think but just
around here so you can whoa well don't
do that please don't
so yeah I think you get my point and
that there we go
the camera is really tripping today I
think the coastal looks pretty cool from
this side as well so I might as well add
a walkway over there but I'll see you
then but for now this is it see you next
time